またね。
はい（ニヤリ）
しょっしょしょはじめしゃちょーです。
あの子ですね、ちょっと言わせていただくと
好き嫌いがマジで多すぎる
ホントに多分皆さんの想像の５倍位あいつ好き嫌いしてるから
ほんとあのねぇ
普通の人間からしたら
「えっ！？そんなにきらいなものあるの？」くらい嫌いなものが多くて
で、唯一好きなのが、
カルピスらしいです（真剣）甘えんじゃねえぞ
おい、おい甘えんじゃねえぞ！一つとか、二つとかならわかるけど、
あいつもうなんか、言うたびになんかあれはいやです、あれはいやですって
もう、嫌なものが多すぎるンスよ。
彼の嫌いなものが、
多すぎるんで
パンッッッ
この僕が責任をもって
彼の好き嫌いを少しでも
治せるようにちょっと頑張ってみようと思います。
つるにい！！
。。。。。
聞こえてないな。今回、えっと、結構部屋が荒れているんですよ。（今回も）
荒れすぎててやばいぜ。。この２本もつるにいのですからね。
いろいろとっ散らかってるわけなんですけど、色々食べ物、飲み物が
散らばってるんですけども、僕ができる限り、あらゆる
食べ物、飲み物にデスソースを入れていこうと思います。
あいつ好き嫌いが多いんで、逆に言えば
好きなものも多いんですよ。好きなものと嫌いなものがはっきり分かれてるんで、
好きなものばっかり食べてちゃだめだよっていうのを教えるために、
彼の好きなものをもうほとんどに、部屋にあるもの全部にデスソース
を混ぜて、もう何食っても何飲んでも何をしても
デスソースが入っているという、最高の苦しみを味わせてやろうとおもいますｗふっへっへっへっへ
っへっへっへっへ
食べかけのチーズバーガーです。
全然わかんないス
うっああぁ・・色が・・
。。。
ｈっヤヴァイｗ
んっ、うめ～～
つるにい！！
はい・・
うぇっ
はい
いい湯だった？
いい湯でしたよ
ちょっ、ダブルチーズバーガー食って・・・残り・・・・
えええ
温めれるやつあります？
ないないない、ちょっ、パクッと
パクッと食っちゃって
えぇ（困惑）パクッと？
うん
ピクルス僕無理っす。。。
ピクルス抜いていいよ、じゃあ
好き嫌い駄目だってホントに。
ぇぃ・・・・・・
ピクルス大っ嫌いなの？
はい
まっ、ピクルスは分かるけどさ、
ピクルスの他に何嫌いなの？
うあああああああああああああああああああああああ！！！！！マジ辛くないスか？
いや、そんなものだと思うよｗ
えぇ？うそぉ！？
なんて言ってる？なんて言ってる？
ほぇ全部食べなひゃいへないんですか
いやまあでもそんなものでしょｗ（二回目）
ハァ？
まって、なんでぁないでぇすか飲むもの
ほ～、はい
ってヤばっっっ
あっはっはっ
アァァァァ！！！！
メッチャ辛いっす
辛いっす
ャう゛ぁ
えっなんか食べな、なんか食べな
ぐっｇ
何か食べなｗ
んはっ・・・・・・
んぁ゛・・・
わぁｗはははははｗｗｗｗｗｗ
やばい！やばいれすよ、これ！
うわぁぁぁ
他の食べなｗ他の食べなｗ
お゛お゛えっ
食べな食べなW
うほおっ
ううううう
えっｇ
うわははははははははは
え、辛いスよ！
これも！
待って
ャヴァイ
もうなんか
探しな何でもいいから
何でもいいからさがしたほうがいいって！
マジで
ホントに
なんでもいいから・・・
死んじゃう死んじゃうｗｗ
どれがあるんすか
え？これえ？
はいすはいす
ぶぇっほ
ふふふふふふｗ
赤いスよｗ
何､何ょｗｗｗｗｗ
食べてみ、食べてみｗ
あ～そうっすねｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
分かんないから
んあ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ！！！！！！
バームクーヘン・・・ｗ
ほえバームフーヘン？
まぁさすがにバームクーヘンは。｡｡
大丈夫？
かむはみはいっすね
ゲフンっ　ちょっとやばいす、これ
そんなにやばい？ｗ
なんか飲む？飲む？飲む？
はい・・・
ん゛えっ
ぺっ
・・・・・・えっ？
ゲホッケホッ　オェっ
あっはっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗ
げっほげっほ
なんすか
これ水道のここにも塗ってあるんだｗ（デスソース）
んぇぇぇぇぇぇっ！
げっほげほ
冷蔵庫冷蔵庫冷蔵庫
冷蔵庫！
大好きなｎ・・・
だはっはっはっはっはｗ
いや分かりますよ
まだまだほかに冷蔵庫冷蔵庫あるまだあるまだある！
何があります？
牛乳とかどう？牛乳・・・ｗ
牛乳僕、メッチャ嫌いっすよ！？
え？嫌いなの？
はい・・・
バカヤロウ！！！！！
他何があります？
あっあっイチゴオレは？
イチゴオレ・・・
イチゴオレめっちゃ嫌いっすよ、ぼく。
イチゴオレ嫌いなのぉ！？！？
イチゴオレ嫌いっすｗ
まぁでも・・・和らぐから
たしかに・・・ぅぐ・・・飲むしかねぇな
うっぐ
あっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
あぁ゛！？
どうするどうするｗｗｗｗｗ
いやまって、まって、コーラは？コーラ
コーラ、はんはんへふ・・・・・・
え？嫌いなのお？　それおまっおま・・・マジでやばいよ！！！！
んごぁ゛
おいおいずるっずるい
おいっおいっｗレモンティーは？レモンティーｗｗｗ
レモンティー嫌いです！
レモンティー嫌いなの？
レモンティーも嫌いなの？
レモンティー嫌い・・・
うわっ辛っ！
はあああああ
下の水道！
水道しかないよw
あっ、つるにぃ！つるにぃ！
ロールケーキだ！！さすがに・・クリームなら大丈夫
ロールケーキ好き？
そうっすね・・・あっ、ロールケーキは好きです
あっ、ロールケーキは好きね・・・ｗ
はっはっはっはｈ
パクッといきな、パクッと
う゛えええからあああっ！！！
水道だ！水道しかないよ！！！
うあっあっあ
んぁ・・・・
げほっ
げほっげほっげほ
これ、好き嫌い関係なくないっすか？